[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL.
WHAT A GORGEOUS SET.
MY GOODNESS.
HAPPY FRIDAY THE 13TH.
WE ALREADY KNOW THIS IS YOUR
LUCKY DAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
WATCHING ME.
A GLORIOUS DAY TO BE ALIVE.
IT SURE BEATS BEING DEAD.
AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT I HEAR
THROUGH MY OUIJA BOARD.
BUT BEING DEAD CAN ONLY MEAN ONE
THING.
YOU'D HAVE TO VOTE DEMOCRAT.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT A CRANKY
PERSON WHO SCREAMS AT PEOPLE.
FOR ONCE I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT
THIS GUY.
I AM TALKING ABOUT PATTING THE
PAWN.
SHE IS A BROADWAY STAR.
SHE'S BEEN AROUND A WHILE.
SHE WAS IN CATS WHEN THEY WERE
STILL KITTENS.
APPARENTLY SHE THINKS HER BELIEF
DOESN'T STINK BUT YOUR BREATH
DOES.
BROADWAY CRANK WAS CAUGHT ON
CAMERA SCREAMING LIKE AN OLD
COOT.
AT A THEATER GORE.
FOLLOWING THE PERFORMANCE OF HER
HIT MUSICAL.
HERE'S A CLIP.
[HOWLING]
>> Greg: THAT GOES ON FOR FOUR
HOURS.
I DON'T SEE THE APPEAL.
HER DIATRIBE WAS RECORDED BY
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE.
RULE LIT.
>> PUT YOUR MASK OVER YOUR NOSE.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO FOLLOW THE
RULE, GET OUT.
>> Greg: WOW AND JUST LIKE
NORTH KOREANS AFTER KIM JONG UN
FINISHES A SPEECH, THE AUDIENCE
CLAPPED.
SHE CONTINUED.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK YOU ARE?
YOU DO NOT RESPECT PEOPLE
SITTING AROUND YOU.
>> Greg: THERE WERE PEOPLE
SITTING AROUND HER, BY THE WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
KEEP IN MIND SHE'S NOT WEARING A
MASK WHILE SHE WAS YELLING WHICH
IS EITHER HYPOCRISY OR A GOOD
THING DEPENDING ON HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT HER FACE.
NOW THE AUDIENCE MEMBER YELLED
BACK "I PAY YOUR SALARY."
LET'S PLAY THAT BACK AND FORTH.
>> YOU PAY MY SALARY.
CHRIS HARPER PAYS MY SALARY.
WHO DO YOU THINK YOU ARE?
JUST PUT YOUR MASK OVER YOUR
NOSE.
>> Greg: WHY WOULD SHE BRING
CHRIS HARPER INTO THIS?
WHO THE HELL IS HE.
ALLEGEDLY SHE STORMED OUT WITH A
PACK OF WHITE CHEDDAR CRACKERS
WHICH IS TYPICALLY RACIST.
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THIS?
DO YOU THINK SHE WAS RIGHT TO
HUMILIATE A CUSTOMER BECAUSE HER
MASK SLIPPED.
WHO THE HELL DOES SHE THINK SHE
IS?
A DELTA FLIGHT ATTENDANT?
NEVER FORGET.
OR WAS SHE BEING AN ELITIST SNOB
WHO DELIGHTS IN FLAUNTING THE
HUGE POWER GAP BETWEEN THE
UNMASKED AND THE MAST.
WHEN I CAN'T MAKE UP MY MIND, I
WATCH "THE VIEW."
WHATEVER [BLEEP] COMES OUT OF
THEIR MOUTHS.
I TAKE THE OPPOSITE STANCE.
THEY LIVE IN A BIZARRE WORLD
WHERE UP AND DOWN, FIRE IS WET
AND JOY BEHAR IS CONSIDERED A
COMEDIAN.
>> GOING TO THE THEATER.
PUT THE MASK OVER YOUR NOSE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO INFECT THE
PEOPLE ON THE STAGE YOU ARE NOT
WEARING.
JUST DO IT RIGHT.
WHY ARE YOU AGITATING
PATTI LUPONE?
>> I WOULD RATHER FIGHT WITH THE
TALIBAN.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE SAID I WANT TO
GO BACK TO WHAT USED TO BE
NORMAL.
WHATEVER THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR
YOU.
YES.
THE SIMPLE ASK OF PUTTING ON A
MASK IS TOO MUCH FOR SOME.
LOOK AT OUR BEAUTIFUL AUDIENCE.
EVERYONE HAS A MASK.
>> Greg: PLEASE DON'T SHOW US
YOUR AUDIENCE.
>> WOW.
>> Greg: THE VOICE OF AN
ANGEL, A HELLS ANGEL BEING
DRAGGED OVER AN ACRE OF BROKEN
GLASS WITHOUT PANTS.
IF THERE WAS EVER A SHOW WHERE
FACES SHOULD BE COVERED.
IF THEY WEAR A MASK, IT SHOULD
BE FILLED WITH OATS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
HOW DARE YOU CLAP AT THAT?
HOW DARE YOU CLAP AT THAT
MISOGYNY!
SHAME ON ALL OF YOU.
I QUICKLY LEARNED A BIG LESSON.
EVERY CELEBRITY AGREES THE
AUDIENCE IS GROSS AND MUST WEAR
MASKS SO THE TALENT DOESN'T HAVE
TO.
GAIN POWER AND WEALTH TO EXEMPT
YOURSELVES FROM THE RULES YOU
DEMAND FROM OTHERS.
IF THEY HAD YOUR WAY, YOU'D BE
UNLOCKED ON FOREVER, YOU'D BE
HOME FROM WORK, WHERE MASKS
FOREVER.
THE ROLE MODELS OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT HANDLING IT.
THEY THINK THEY ARE BETTER THAN
YOU.
THEY CAN GO TO BED.
THEY CAN HAVE SERVICE TRAIL
BEHIND THE HILLARYS OF THE WORLD
HOLDING HER TRAIN, NOT THE ONE
JOE BIDEN STILL PLAYS WITH UNDER
THE CHRISTMAS TREE.
NOT THE ONE BILL CLINTON
PARTICIPATES IN UNDER THE
CHRISTMAS TREE.
THEY COULD GO.
[APPLAUSE]
THEY CAN GO TO PRICEY
RESTAURANTS MASKLESS AND GET
WAITED ON BY THE MASK.
JUST LAST NIGHT HERE IS
PATTI LUPONE AT THE TONY AWARDS
NOMINEES EVENT.
I WASN'T INVITED.
WITHOUT A MASK.
CLEARLY SHE WANTS EVERYONE TO
DIE.
WHAT A CLEAR MARKER OF STATUS.
YOU CAN SEE MY MOUTH BUT I CAN
SEE YOURS.
YOU SERVE INTO.
ME MASTER.
THE MESSAGE, YOU ARE DOING IT TO
PROTECT ME FROM YOU AND YOUR
MODERN-DAY LEPROSY.
NOW FETCH ME A ROLLOUT OR I WILL
HAVE YOU FIRED FROM YOUR PRESENT
WORK.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
SIR.
YOU, YEAH, YOU, YOUNG MAN IN THE
POLO SHIRT IN THE SECOND ROW.
WHERE IS YOUR MASK?
I TOLD YOU TO PUT ON YOUR MASK.
PUT IT ON!
[APPLAUSE]
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
NOW REMEMBER TO MEET ME AFTER
THE SHOW IN MY HOTEL.
IT'S THE SAME DEAL AS BEFORE.
DON'T FORGET THE COOL WHIP OR
YOU DON'T GET A TIP.
ANYWAY.
PATTI LUPONE'S OUTBURST IS
FURTHER PROOF WE MOVE INTO WORLD
BUT IT'S NOT A RACIAL DIVIDE OR
A GENDER DIVIDE.
IT'S BEEN WHAT IT'S ALWAYS BEEN.
THE ELITES VERSUS THE REST OF US
DIRTY, GRIMY COMMONERS.
WE SEE WHOSE MASK HAS REALLY
SLIPPED, THERE IS.
THAT'S WHY I DON'T GO TO
MUSICALS.
IF I WANT TO PAY MONEY HAVE A
ANGRY LADY YELL AT ME I WILL GO
TO JUDGE JEANINE'S HOUSE.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
HE IS SO PATRIOTIC HE DONATES
HIS HAIR TO BALD EAGLES.
COHOST OF "FOX & FRIENDS"
WEEKEND, PETE HEGSETH.
HER SMILES ALWAYS PEARLY AND
SHE'S ON AIR TOO DAM EARLY.
CARLEY SHIMKUS.
SHE IS LIKE A SLICE OF
WONDER BREAD.
THIN, WHITE, ALREADY BAKED.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
FINALLY, CHILDREN USE HIS SHOES
AS BUMPER CARS.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE
N.W.A. CHAMPION.
TYRUS.
PETE, LOOKING GOOD TODAY AS
ALWAYS.
I WOULD PUT YOU UP AT
A 8 TONIGHT.
USUALLY YOU ARE BETWEEN
A 7 AND 9.
>> Pete: THIS STUDIO IS A 10.
>> Greg: IT CERTAINLY IS.
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS BEAUTIFUL,
YOU.
THEIR LOGIC IS THEY ARE TELLING
THEIR AUDIENCE YOU WEAR THESE SO
WE CAN PERFORM.
ISN'T THAT AN ARTIFICIAL DIVIDE?
YOU DON'T NEED TO WEAR THEM.
IT'S CRAZY, IT'S ACTUALLY
PRETENDING IT IS SCIENCE OR THEY
DON'T WEAR THEM BUT YOU DO.
>> Pete: .
WE KNOW MOST OF THE MASKS ARE
CLOTH MASKS WHICH WE KNOW DON'T
WORK.
IT'S THE ULTIMATE VIRTUE SIGNAL.
IF THEY COULD REPLACE THE CLOTH
DIAPER OVER THEIR FACE WITH A
BUTTON THAT SAYS I'M BETTER THAN
YOU, THAT WOULD WORK OUT WELL
FOR EVERYBODY.
AND YET IT'S -- IF TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME WAS ONE
THING, THIS IS COVID DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME.
IF THE VACCINES WORK SO WELL
WHICH THEY WORSHIP, THEN WE
SHOULD ALL BE JUST FINE.
BUT IF THEY HAD NOT ORIGINATED
FROM DONALD TRUMP.
PLAY THIS GAME TOO MUCH BUT IN
THIS CASE IF THE VACCINES HAD
COME -- NOT COME FROM
DONALD TRUMP AND WE WERE ALL
GETTING COVID EVEN THOUGH WE
WERE VACCINATED, THEY WOULD SAY
THEY DON'T WORK.
VACCINES DON'T WORK AND THEY
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT ADVERSE
CONDITIONS SO THEY ALWAYS HAVE A
DOUBLE STANDARD WHICH IS THE
ONLY STANDARD THE LEFT HAS,
DOUBLE STANDARDS.
IN THIS CASE, I FEEL BAD.
EVERYWHERE I GO WHERE I DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK AND SOMEONE
ELSE DOES.
I WOULD SAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
REMOVE YOUR MASK, YOU ABSOLUTELY
CAN.
>> Greg: THAT CLUB WE GO TO.
CARLEY, TECHNICALLY THE AUDIENCE
MEMBER IS CORRECT.
THEY DO PAY HER SALARY.
THE PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE RIGHT
NOW, THEY PAY OUR SALARY.
>> Carley: AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING.
YOU DESERVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
WE LOVE YOU.
IF COVID IS SUCH A
LIFE-THREATENING DANGER TO THIS
PERSON THAT SHE STOPS A BROADWAY
SHOW TO YELL AT SOMEBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE 50 FEET AWAY FROM HER
WHO DOESN'T HAVE THEIR MASK JUST
OVER THEIR NOSE, THEN MAYBE SHE
SHOULDN'T BE IN PUBLIC.
THAT'S FINE.
EVERYBODY'S GOT THEIR OWN RISK
ASSESSMENT OF THE WORLD COULD BE
TOO MUCH OF A DANGEROUS PLACE
FOR HER OR THEY COULD NOT BE
ABOUT COVID AT ALL OR FOLLOWING
THE SCIENCE AND EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH CLAIMING THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND.
THE THING I FOUND SO INTERESTING
IS THAT MEDIA EIGHT THAT UP.
EVERY SINGLE HEADLINE WAS
PATTI LUPONE.
NOT PATTY WILL PAWN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS
PATTI LaBELLE.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
>> Greg: I GUESS THEY ALL LOOK
ALIKE.
>> STOPPING A BROADWAY SHOW TO
YELL AT A ANTI-MASTER.
THEY ARE SAYING GOOD JOB FOR
YELLING AT SMELLY WALMART
SHOPPER, TRUMP FOLLOW HER.
SHE THE RIGHT THING.
>> Greg: I'VE BEEN WONDERING,
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE DONE?
PRETENDING --
>> Kat: I WOULD NEVER BE
THERE.
IT WAS A Q&A ABOUT A BROADWAY
MUSICAL.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST GROUP OF
LOSERS IN THE WORLD.
>> Greg: ONE STEP REMOVED.
>> Kat: ALREADY HORRIBLE.
I DON'T CARE IF I PISS THESE
PEOPLE OFF BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO HANG AROUND WITH THEM ANYWAY.
SORRY, WHAT WAS YOUR QUESTION?
>> Greg: LET'S PUT IT ANOTHER
WAY.
WHAT IF YOU HAD TO COVER UP FOR
FOX SO YOU WERE IN THE AUDIENCE
AGAINST YOUR CHOICE AND YOUR
MASK AND A CRAZY LADY AT YOU.
>> Kat: THAT I WOULDN'T MIND.
IT WOULDN'T MAKE IT FUN.
I WOULD GET SOME ATTENTION.
I'VE GONE "FOX & FRIENDS" AND BE
LIKE "I'M A VICTIM."
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> Pete: YOUR BOOK TOMORROW.
>> Kat: I'M NOT.
I'M BUSY.
>> Greg: IT IS ABOUT THE HOUR,
NOT ABOUT THE SHOW.
>> Kat: IF YOU WANT TO DO A
PRETAPE, WE WILL DO A PRETAPED.
>> Greg: WHEN YOUR SHOW IS ON
SHE IS JUST GETTING READY TO
LEAVE THE BAR.
>> Kat: I DON'T LIKE RULES IN
GENERAL.
BEHIND EVERY RULE IS THE
IMPLICATION I CAN'T MAKE A
DECISION FOR MYSELF FOR THE
WORST KIND OF RULES ARE WHEN
YOU'RE ASKING SOMEBODY TO DO
SOMETHING THAT YOU CLEARLY WON'T
DO FOR YOURSELF.
AND THEN JUST TO BERATE AND
SCREAM AT SOMEBODY ABOUT IT.
SHE SAID IT WAS AN ISSUE IF THAT
PERSON BEING DISRESPECTFUL BUT
CLEARLY SHE DISRESPECTS THAT
PERSON BECAUSE ALL THE PEOPLE ON
STAGE, SHE DOESN'T CARE IF THEY
BREATHE ON HER.
>> Greg: THEY ARE PACKED NEXT
TO HER.
THEY ARE PROBABLY ALL DEAD RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T HAVE ANY RESEARCH TO
BACK THAT UP.
BUT I'M ASSUMING, LET'S ASSUME
THEY ALL DIED AND SHE IS A
MONSTER.
SHE IS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A BREAK.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> NO, NO, NO!
I UNDERSTAND WHAT A PERFORMER
FEELS LIKE WHEN THEY ARE HECKLED
BY SOMEBODY AND I BELIEVE WE
WATCHED THE SHOW LAST NIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
GUTFELD.
YOUR STAFF CARES ABOUT YOU AND
THEY PUT A PAD ON IT BUT HERE'S
THE FUNNY THING, THE OTHER SIDE
IS NOT HAVE A PAD.
HOW DO YOU WANT TO HANDLE THIS?
>> Greg: ALL I SAID WAS THAT
WHEN SOMEBODY CALLED SOMEBODY A
RACIST ON TV IT'S LIKE GETTING
HIT WITH THE CHAIR AND I DID --
I DID SAY IT WAS REAL.
>> Kat: YOU ACTUALLY SAID IT
WAS NOT REAL.
>> THANK YOU, I BELIEVE THE WORD
WAS PHONY.
I TELL YOU WHAT, GUTFELD, I'LL
GIVE YOU A PASS.
I'LL GIVE YOU A PASS BUT NEXT
TIME.
HE LIKES TO RUN, RIGHT?
IT WILL BE YOUR ASS.
SHE IS A HORRIBLE PERSON.
OBVIOUSLY SHE NEEDED SOME
ATTENTION.
I'M GOING TO KEEP THIS RIGHT
HERE IN CASE YOU GET SMART.
>> Pete: I WILL STAND IN IF
YOU NEED ME.
>> Tyrus: IT'S NOT FOR FUN.
IT'S NOT FOR YOUR THING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THE POTENTIAL FOR
LITTLE PAIN, HE'S LIKE I'LL TAKE